[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm red this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring what happened over break man
hey Rhett what happened over break I
don't know we haven't talked about it
because we want to talk about it on air
biscuits man I'm gonna tell you what
happened over my break this is my 2019
voice my where we 2019 I'm regressing
post break
it's a syrupy and southern earth than
normal yeah man cuz because because we
did that thing where we we bit we've
been back we've been doing a little work
we've been doing some stuff we've been
holding back our full reports it's like
when you held it in it can't care away
for a week right or every day at school
I mean you never took a dump at school I
I can probably with 98% confidence say
never but for all of for all of my grade
school middle school in high school
never once did a number two at school
and now let me just interject for a
second and say I did not know this is
what the conversation was gonna be I'm
sorry I brought it up I don't
necessarily want to that's what I call
perfect attendance one but but I will
say I didn't make a habit of it it
wasn't like here at work where I'm kind
of looks like a clock you know you have
your tea oh yeah I I wait to do it here
at work cuz that that gives me something
to do here at work cuz right what else
am I gonna do work yeah but at school
because the facilities are usually
semi-public
soiled it's in some form well all the
other kids see sneakers and yeah your
pants are on yeah you got to have your
Dookie shoes you take your Dookie shoes
how do you find on your backpack you
take your backpack to the stall you get
your Dookie shoes out you put them down
nobody knows it's you well I gotta tell
Lando that yeah if you had Dookie shoes
you can crap as much as you want oh
that's cool none of my kids know about a
Dookie shoes no because that is not a
thing right of course they don't know
that my kids don't either and I didn't
make a practice of it but I'd say
probably at least a dozen times over
my school career I ended up having to
drop a load at school I mean I'm a I'm a
person man just a human
20:19 I am I am a professional anal
retentive human so bye
I'm sorry to get graphic but by
definition I'm good at that you are
thank you right so I haven't so we got
the lot to kit we got a lot to unload
yeah we're gonna you know we're gonna
move right on from that so I did a
little uh and this is for real by the
way
the last time we talked about this we
were it was before the break and we were
we were Josh and I specifically I did
want to talk to you about your wife
because your wife indirectly hurt me
over the break and I hope emotionally
and you know okay so on Ellen I have no
clue what you're talking to I don't know
exactly when things happen I just know
that this podcast will be live for
everyone to listen to after the elta
after the Yaletown yeah yeah we talked
about this so yeah see that's all that's
what you mentioned it you talked about
that photo I saw the photo and I was
like asking about what's wrong with your
leg give a little more context for the
photo shoot later when we talk about our
respective trips but I did have a photo
shoot in Cabo San Lucas in which I was
wearing a watermelon outfits that we
talked about on elta and Link I was a
little self-conscious about it but link
did did point out what's up on with your
leg what is that stripe on your leg I
thought it was yours past that her to
him I thought I mean you were standing
on the beach I just thought that your
leg hairs had like formed a rivulet
absurd the wind I thought it was like
wetness formed a hair rivulet on your
right shin it was a scar what it was it
was a it was a scab that but if you had
a seen it - two or three days before
that it would have been like black scab
in that whoa in that formation
it's your wife's fault here's from what
I saw of it it was the rivulet or scab
was I mean it was eight inches yeah it
was all a little bit of an s-curve you
want to know how it happened and I won't
tell you what I'm making up in my mind
is probably a lot better so as you know
we and some of our close friends decided
to do Secret Santa and the way that it
was organized by one of our friends who
took the initiative was there was some
website it's not sync Rossano combo it's
something like that and you go and you
put everybody in to a hat essentially a
digital hat and then you find out who
you have to be the Secret Santa for I
can't write I would like to remember it
it's called but it can't if they're a
sponsor I definitely would I will say
that and I do like it because when you
get when you get your assignment then
you can click on the person and they
have the option to put something that
they on their wish list something they
would like but only one person did that
only one person in our group put what
they wanted on their wish list and it
was a person that my wife got the gift
no actually my person did too and he
said I just want you to give and he gave
listed out some charities he said I'd
like for you to give all charities in my
name and I'm I ain't doing I know who
that was that's not fun yeah I did give
to charity but also gave him something
that he has a gift or the receipt no I
guess so
yeah I drew your wife and you can you
say Christy no let's call your wife okay
I drew Christy don't you say my wife's
name and I was actually pretty excited
about having your wife as a Secret Santa
receiver but what you didn't know was
she also drew your name no she didn't oh
she didn't know oh I thought she did
know William did oh I don't know what I
thought that nevermind so you drew her
name that's all that happened I drew her
name and I was excited about it because
as you know and I don't know if we've
really discussed this but Christy and I
have very similar tastes as
when it comes to food literally and like
chances are and first of all I kind of
like everything she kind of likes
everything but things very specifically
like olives or cheese or things that
taste a little bit weird I we tend to
agree on those things and so especially
the things that her and I disagree on
and you and I disagree on those things
together you both really like
passionately right and so I thought I'm
gonna go this is kind of a fun exercise
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna shop for her
as if I'm shopping for myself because if
I get things that I would like then
that's kind of getting the things that
she would like right and so and this was
a day in which I was doing quite a bit
I'll tell you some other things I was
doing that day and other gifts I was
getting for people but it was
essentially like it's like December 23rd
Jesse's parents have been in town and
then Jesse's sister and her family were
coming into town and there was a just a
couple of days before Christmas that we
had to kind of take care of business and
so I kind of went out on my own and did
a bunch of last-minute shop this is go
time for Jesse for Christy your wife
from my kids
oh one gift in particular for Shepherd
that I'll talk about later a little
something from me maybe yeah and of
course and your wife being happy is your
gift and so I but you making my wife
happy is not my gift that's just weird
now I was talking to my wife Jesse to
figure out what to get you don't you say
her name your wife Christy and or
no I was asking her a question because I
was like you know the kinds of things
that I like where should I go to get
those things is this like a whole food
situation mm-hmm
she's like well there's this place I
think it's in Pasadena it's good they
got like kombucha and like fermented
things and I think that she'd be really
into it it turns out the place was in
like Altadena
I think I can't remember exactly where
it was north of Pasadena and so I go and
I see the again if they were a sponsor
you'd know yeah and I see the place I'm
gonna talk a little crap about the place
so I don't want to say the name of the
place but I see the place and it's in
one of those situations where
it's kind of like a little downtown area
but then there was a Rite Aid
catty-corner across the street across
the corner with a parking lot but it
said for Rite Aid customers only and
there was a guy sitting next to his car
in a lawn chair and it seemed like he
was like the guy that Rite Aid pays to
make sure nobody violates the parking
situation I don't know why else he would
be there it was a little strange okay
and I don't know if he's like a shop
owner of one of the other places
whatever he had like some like a bowl of
food that he was eating on the back of
the car he was sitting next to as well
so he was bound to that location yeah
and so I was like well I'm gonna pull
the old yeah you know the old I'm go to
Rite Aid Winky Winky I don't I was
trying to come up with a name for it but
the Rite Aid Winky Winky yeah so I went
into the Rite Aid and went in and did
you talk to the bowl eater
oh man you parked there's what you're
saying I parked at Rite Aid I walked in
I did a loop and I came back out Oh what
nothing nothing I was gonna get
something like chapstick something you
could always use but there's a line we
have that we make that we make it
ourselves exactly why do I need that so
I come back out and then I walk through
the parking lot and I walk down to this
other place turns out they did not have
any of the stuff that my wife had
basically indicated they might have they
they had stuff that you could get like
fresh made right there but they didn't
have like I thought they're gonna have
like jars of pickled things and the
stuff that I like that your wife would
like you know I wanted to give her some
like pickled okra I did end up finding
pickled asparagus at Whole Foods
later bone broth and other things but
I'm a little pissed because I didn't get
anything and I've driven language I've
driven you know the Alta Dena of all
places and and then I come back and I
just gone to Dena that's right and then
I see
well you know what's so wrong with Dena
that they had to invent an alternate I
crossed over the the road and at this
point I have the choice of walking
around
the barrier because my car is right
there like um there's a corner in there
and there's a wall in my car is parked
right and we're talking like a cinder
block yeah a collie
wall three feet tall three feet oh and
somehow a big man three feet is not big
for me you didn't want to walk next to
the kind with no no no I didn't want to
walk all the way around the wall and
then come all the way through the
parking lot had nothing to do with the
guy cuz at this point I'm getting my car
it doesn't matter if he knows I did the
the rite-aid Winky Winky he doesn't care
anymore does he get my license plate and
send the cops after me I don't think so
might not let you leave so I wasn't
thinking about him at all I was just
thinking about efficiency of getting
back into my car and actually getting to
a store to get your wife what she wanted
and so I was like well I'm gonna do that
thing when you throw your legs over a
fence it's been years since I've done
this okay and so I get up there like a
rodeo cowboy throw your legs to the side
and get on a bull and I put my hands on
the wall throw my legs up pommel horse
and then as I make eye contact with the
ground on the other side I realize oh
it's higher on the other side this is
not an even wall oh and so instead of
just 30 feet I'm not saying it was you
know it my side was three feet the other
side was four feet it wasn't okay it
wasn't this huge drop but you had to
make it a job I had to do mate I had to
think oh and in the process of thinking
you forgot about that I'm trailing leg
I've bent my right leg as opposed to
keeping it flying over and in the press
it had jeans on had jeans Oh cuz they
give you an idea good my shin hits the
top of the concrete and just like the
corner of the concrete and like breaks
my full body weight like rakes on it all
the way down my shin are the eight
inches or whatever it was that it took
and I in I land and I'm like oh no oh no
I may have broken my leg the first thing
I thought was I may have broken my leg
because it was you know the front of
your shin is I'd really really sharp
and outdoors is special I thought I had
like done I had done something
thankfully I was able to get into my car
car was right there if I had to walk
across the parking lot I don't know if I
would have made it did you think about
calling football man I got into my I
think I might have broken my leg I get
into my time to obfuscate walking past
you I get in my car shut the door and I
just rise like I was like it wouldn't
stop hurting and I was like no you have
not seriously done something serious to
yourself I mean it was hurting to like
press the gas in the brake did you roll
up your pant leg and I couldn't my pants
are too tight you know I'm saying and it
was like my jeans are tight so I'm like
pulling them up and like they're
grabbing on to the flesh that has been
scarred through my jeans the jeans these
are fine these are fine so anyway and
I'd like to think at that point it's
like you before you put it in Drive you
look up and he's standing right outside
of your door just watching I would have
no defenses against him I would have let
him arrest he's like two twenty dollars
citizens right you didn't buy anything
at Rite Aid through this he would have
escorted me in to ride a and I would
have the guys get some nice thrifty ice
cream I'm going with you to get some
chapstick or your pain so that you can't
fake an injury I ended up about it
getting to Whole Foods and getting your
wife's and things and she seemed to be
very happy she actually texted me a
picture of some of the stuff that she
was enjoying okay and I was like great
pickle disparity is it good I did not
taste that and anyway so a couple of
days after this I noticed my leg has got
this massive like it's scabbed up like I
wasn't seriously hurt it was just a
superficial wound but I got this like it
looked like the Hawaiian Islands it was
like this archipelago you know what I'm
saying of just scabby tissue that
eventually by the time I got to Mexico
it was falling off and then when I took
my picture it was just sort of a red
streak and it's probably almost gone now
but it's you know she Weiss fought but I
think she was happy and I'm happy that
she was happy and it's a small price to
pay
man did I get hurt you know what NOPA
didn't know injuries for the linkster of
the holidays that was coasting man
Koston I had a wonderful time
I had a moved to tears multiple times
time over the holidays and I'll get into
all that moved to tears yeah that's
quite a teaser but first let's get into
some ads because let's be real the name
of this podcast is ear biscuits as you
can see I'm wearing a shirt that says
your biscuits I'm drinking from a mug
that says your biscuits not too long ago
I would have thought that this was over
branding and pretentious and then I got
a little desperate and at that point I
just started over over branding myself
and I'm okay with it now and whether you
are not I'm not really concerned about
that I'm I feel good about myself I feel
good about myself in 2019 and I and I
really feel great in this shirt that you
can get at rhettandlink.com/store I
think if you go to
rhettandlink.com/store it'll still go to
Rack but it's actually we're not
changing it back in 2019 that was just a
little Rite Aid Winky Winky not a
sponsor mythical dog when you came out
yeah anyway I like this mug it's good
it's got speckle get the set of three so
you can rep all of our major properties
while you're drinking your beverages for
those of you with three arms we could
drink all at the same time I think there
was a you know the the question was
really how is this going to play out us
being in Los Angeles for our first
Christmases yeah we saw each other on
Christmas Eve we got together we did
that dirty Santa thing where your moat
where you can present a dirty sense of
difference yeah you're right
Secret Santa it wasn't that special that
was something that was unexpected to
have a bunch of friends over at my house
yeah and and we did something that has
never been done before
get in my present wasn't planned it was
weird you tell my the countdown the
counting down to the to the coming in of
Christmas yeah to the Chart of Christmas
from Christmas Eve and it was like New
Year's Eve this you know the strike of
the new year but it
Christmas instead and we had our group
of friends and all their kids all
together literally chanting playing the
guitar chanting with what is the song
that was you I missed that just shark
the shark the the shark song oh gosh it
was some like I can't remember it right
now I don't know what it is what do you
remember the tune of the countdown that
we did 7 minutes 7 minutes I don't know
about this I'm out of the loop and I'm
not getting gifts for your wife I don't
with the shark song apparently was
something that was big it's the kids
song anyway so we sang that and I went
downstairs to the garage and the floor
was buckling under everyone jumping up
and down I was like should I stop the
celebration I mean if they all fall into
my garage it's not worth it that was
special man it was fun and is there
gonna be a tradition that was what I was
thinking as it was happening I need to
get two by sixes in the in the floor of
course you know me I almost missed it
cuz I was you know I was trying to
gather up my children and go home like
and how are your trying to get out of
there but I heard all this chanting and
I gathered up my keys and like I you
know the food that leftovers that nobody
ate that we brought in like I was
gathered up and ready to like head out
the door and you know get on get on with
the Christmas getting ready for
Christmas morning I had cuz we had plans
and then we're about to go out the door
and I realized wow this chanting thing
is like everybody's all in and it's
their scene 14 minutes so at least you
knew how long you had yes and I'm like
well if I can stay for 14 minutes and
then lo and behold like literally every
every millisecond of that was part of a
countdown leading up to him we stayed
for and that was amazing that was a
great start then we go home and you know
i'ma leave Santa out of this all right
understood no no no no no what I'm
talking about has anything to do with
what Santa did at my house this is I'm
only going to talk about the part that
me and Kristi
got it all right so the Supplemental
stuff yeah so in addition to anything
Santa did or might have done or wanted
to do or wished he had done Christy and
I had our own plan that the kids didn't
know about that we needed to put into
action that night I'm pretty sure this
is Christy's idea but I was the moment
she said it like we were we were out on
a date we're like we got a you know we
were talking about we got it we got to
figure out what we're gonna do this is
our first Christmas here in LA with the
kids as opposed to going back home we
got to start developing some traditions
you know like I've been talking about
and then she pitched this idea and I
immediately knew as she started to pitch
it just jump on board don't even analyze
it you know how I have a tendency to
like oh really we can analyze yeah but I
can do this and it would be better or
what if we did I was like I was just yes
man there's a it was a brilliant idea
it was that more of them yes with her
the idea it was Christmas morning
scavenger hunt kids are gonna come down
well we don't have an upstairs we do but
it's just me and Christy's upstairs
they're all the houses downstairs for
everybody else you know you got a is the
pecking order here so they're all
downstairs so they all you know they're
gonna flow out into you know and and go
to the Christmas tree where all the
presents are and then they're gonna find
out Oh tree the tree was like full of
presents under there so we moved all of
them and hid them all around the house
outside of the house in the washing
machine in the grill in the car and then
we had one bear unwrapped with a card on
it and it had the first clue and boy we
were so excited you know and then you'd
open that up and it was it was a it was
a letter and it was
the bear no and it a letter from us and
it was it was um it even arrived it was
a poem that I wrote
EMN and at the end it had the first clue
to find the presence and we were so
excited of course you know I'm staying
up till like 2:00 a.m. that's just
something that's not something that I do
I'm no elf but I did it because we were
excited so then we get down there and
we're like Lando came up to our bedroom
first before he went in there and then
he got he woke Lily up him she's 15
turns out by the time he turned 15 if
you don't have to go to school you could
literally sleep into the afternoon for
you know 4 days yeah like I know I don't
know if we don't wake her up I just
don't know when she would ever wake up
and Lincoln knew that he was getting an
electric guitar so he wasn't too
motivated to get out of bed either so we
get them out of bed we're like okay go
in there get the presents and then we're
like watch it and they go in there and
they're you know it's ah joke's on you
that presents aren't here and they're
like kind of groggy and and then Lando's
the most excited I mean he's eight and
he's like opening the card and the
reading of the poem and like at this
point I expect like celebration
scavenger hunt
like you know you could have consulted
what seems obvious to me now is that
it's like Christmas morning you run
downstairs and all the presents are gone
and there's nothing but a letter and we
have to answer a riddle so it was they
were they were a little underwhelmed
yeah maybe you should have been a little
boy I thought he said maybe I need have
been a little more animate no no like
dude I was animated I was like scavenger
hunt guys yeah so how did so what ended
up happening well they had to solve the
riddles did forget their presents so
then so by the time they found the third
president they were waking up more it
was kind of like there's like a delayed
reaction of the scavenger hunt it's like
it's like an you you
get to your third clue it's like an
infusion of caffeine really they kind of
got on board in my experience scavenger
hunts really hot out of the gate you
don't think and only go downhill I think
that they saw the look on my face of
disappointment and like still hope and
expectation that this like let's just do
this for Dad
yeah okay so and is this a tradition
they got into it and then so and when
they found the presents they were still
wrapped by the way well yeah so and so
then they would they would take the
presents and they would put them in a
pile or like separate them and then they
would after a while what point did it
become more of an Easter egg hunt do you
have to follow the clues because you got
to follow the clues but you know maybe
ones in the washing machine I think
there were ten they're all there were
ten locations okay total yeah total they
worked as a team to get everything as a
team so each location would have
multiple presents like one for each kid
kind of thing and they came around to it
and then I really think is about now
next year yes it is a tradition we are
gonna do it and they're there they're
gonna be emotionally prepared you're
gonna hire a scavenger hunt company to
do it right yourself what do you mean
you know my clues were were lit like a
tree man
so we're gonna do that so that they said
then we were back to square one they
were opening the presents and then we
were proceeding from there and it was it
was goodbye and we we actually both got
our kids an electric guitar
you got Lincoln when I got Locke one no
I went with I went with Locke so he
could pick it out yeah so oh that's what
Lincoln had already seen is we went we
picked out the guitar that he wanted he
wanted him a a Telecaster form of course
I'm not going to get him an actual
Telecaster I don't like the the
preliminary version of the Telecaster
the squire Telecaster and we got there's
gotta prove himself before he moves to
the big leagues did you do when you were
at the guitar shop did you see the
Jaguar the Fender Jaguar
in the same thing it's like a squire we
just had a apron over it what no that's
what we ended up getting beat what
you are Jaguar is it made by fender yeah
it's a it is a shape that you would
recognize that I think is a little
different as master no it's just a
different it's just a different shape
it's got a few more bells and whistles
not that it necessarily does anything he
said all the same price there like all
and that okay I'm Squire range but I
knew that you had got in the Telecaster
I'm thinking about turning my garage
into a like a garage band yeah that's
what it looks like yeah that's the
that's a that's a jazz master body okay
same thing then
but it says Jaguar in it cool colors and
we almost got that one but that one was
more expensive the people know more than
me and that's probably wrong so we got
like a candy apple red one you know you
got him an amp I'm saying about turning
the garage into it yeah got an amp where
champ did you get a Fender the one that
has the built the stuff built into it
like tuned to sounds yeah yeah yeah I
got the same man it was like a hundred
bucks they could it wasn't that much
more expensive but it was another book
maybe I got the same amp but I just got
a better deal okay all right yeah but
they but you're gonna turn did you hide
it
no there you go I but the most exciting
gift that that I got was for Shepherd
though because Shepherd as you may
recall on the good mythical more more
went out well in in in the episode we
went over the filling in the blank on
Christmas list but then in good mythical
more they went over their list and I
watched that back we watched that back
as a family because I was like Shepherd
have you watched the show that you were
on yeah he was like no this is like a
week after I'd been out uh-huh
and so we sat down Jesse and Shepherd
and I watched Shepherd on the show and
then we watched good mythical more and
that was when I realized that oh you
know when he went through his Christmas
list like that was actually a real thing
it wasn't yeah it wasn't just for
entertainment purposes that's the way I
think about the show is like we've had
these conversations right oh there's
there's no real world application
we said we're gonna do this but we're
not right you you don't really like wood
exactly so so I am I hold on okay just
tell me cuz I remember what he he said
say I wanted a snake you want a reptile
this or something from the reptile
family how about a snake okay
I remember did you get him I got him a
snake
well cuz Jesse was like he was like she
she she saw him mention sting she's like
oh you still want a snake like he been
talking to her about how he wants snake
and so I don't yeah I kind of thought
Shepherd was just being Shepherd when he
said he would I don't mind snakes and I
thought that this might be an
opportunity for him to get a little
responsibility or something to have to
take care of the snake so yeah I'm sure
the snake appreciates that I learn
responsibility or kill us you know I
mean you got away you got away the the
pros and cons here I'm gonna mammal I'm
gonna step in and take care of this
cold-blooded animal as needed you got a
snake yeah so we got a so first of all
how you wrap us night well the first
snake we did wrap know so you don't wrap
a snake but what I did do is I went to
the pet store here in Burbank that we
that we got Craig from actually the one
really they try to take Craig back to
because this place has a bunch of
reptiles great pet store ID scales and
tails I'll shut him out not a sponsor
not a sponsor but of anything basically
the place in Burbank to get pets but
definitely get reptiles and in with sort
of exotic pets and that kind of thing so
I go in there and I have my mind set on
a corn snake and a little bit of reading
I have done that you know corn snakes
are great for your first snake and you
can get like these weird colors and
stuff we got the I think they call it
the
Okeechobee mutation which is makes them
they're like orange and orange and red
okay as a mutation not normal you safe
when you get your first snake as if you
play
on getting more snake no I mean this is
the first and probably the last snake
but I'm saying I don't want to get
something that you have to like think
about a whole lot it's not let's take
around its like as big around as my
thumb right yeah but it could they can
go to six feet long more likely four
feet long is what this thing they're
fast too aren't they yeah it's an it's a
lively state away they'd like to be
handled and like I think they or get
away why yeah I mean they could get away
but we know the protocol but I had to
come here I actually to come here to
like put because they just give you the
snake in a little plastic like something
you'd get you'd get takeout at a
restaurant where that's what they put
the snake in I was like I'm not
interested in eating the snake is I know
this is how we this is how we transport
the snakes little paper towel and some
holes in this little plastic like a
wonton yeah and mmm then they give you
the whole setup and you got like you got
this you know your heat lamp and there's
like a pad and anything you have a hot
side and a cold side there's water you
know all that I came here to do all this
like you know Christmas Eve no no two
days before Christmas and so the snake
who Shepard ended up naming moose
by the way moose the snake that's cool
was in our office sealed up you know he
couldn't get out of the terrarium but
the minute I'm just gonna talk to you
about the the disturbing side of reptile
ownership because this is something that
I not anticipated but I kind of
understood I mean I know I I think I
think I understand it's called just
having a snake that's disturbing it gets
dark it's gonna get dark her so again I
don't mind this the snake he seems kind
of almost kind of cute first of all you
we don't know if it's a male or a female
apparently finding out the the sex of
the snake involves a probe of some kind
and you got to kind of be like an expert
like it's not just like you just turned
it over and look at it and so like even
the guy was I don't know if it's a male
or a female and I'm not in the
implication was and I'm not about to
find out for you so we just went with
moose it could be a male or a female
right there our plan on breeding it
there are male and female meats and so
but I'm like so what
feed it so all you you you feed it
pinkies for months
hands the smallest finger on each with
my hands eight McGlothlin pink that's
not gonna last long he's like these baby
mice like that's that's there's no
alternatives like baby hairless mice so
the dude proceeds to and listen if you
are like super animal lover do you may
want to skip this part because basically
they have mice live mice in the pet
store at different stages and he's like
he reaches in he reaches in he's like it
this is what you're gonna start feeding
him and he just pulls out this little
teeny baby mouse that has no hair on it
it looks like just something that just
popped out of oh gosh like a little
little preemie looking thing gosh
like can't even see and he's like yeah
you're gonna take it you're gonna put it
in the bag with the snake now Ethan he
says but you can get frozen I was like
yes I want frozen so first of all I
didn't I wasn't gonna deal with the live
situation which technically a lot of
people including this guy said that you
know if you want to be safe you give
them frozen from from the beginning and
frozen from then on out so that they
can't get injured because you know a
mouse will bite a snake as it's going
down you know and okay but these people
just so you understand I wasn't in the
market for a snake why are you dying to
talk about of it because I just want you
to understand the reality people have
and and I don't know I've never thought
about this but people who have snakes
he's like as it gets older you're gonna
want to continue to go up he's like
there's pinkies and then there's he
caught him like soft teeth or something
or Fluffy's and he's gonna small mice
and then large mice okay and Craig also
eats frozen mice as well so we're doing
all frozen here but these are just mice
that is bred in order to be given to
reptiles and this was our happy holiday
episode no no
/ what the interesting thing is is that
on the like you know animal ethics scale
you've got these more developed mammals
yeah yeah like I said earlier it's not a
mammal more closely related to us they
had they actually have a you know an
another part of their brain that like
gives them the opportunity to process
thoughts on a different level and to
like enjoy bonding and this stuff and
we're feeding it to the lower life-form
the snake because this is the way that
the world works there are no vegan
snakes and so then I was like does this
mean that there are no vegan snake
owners or if a vegan snake owner has a
snake that is like well I'm not eating
the mice he's eating the mice I don't
understand the ethics of it left a snake
snake I'm not a vegan I understand that
we're all part of the food chain I
understand that this is what snake
ownership involves and I'm but I'm not
gonna deal with the live ones I'm gonna
deal with the frozen ones and I really
don't want to know what happens before
that you got a microwave from before you
throw them in the cage you can but you
shouldn't you just set it out and let it
fall
if you microwave it you can it's uneven
and can get hot in certain places it can
injure your snake okay so what I do is I
take the snake I put it into this is
what this guy says you put it into a
little brown bag with the thawed mice
Mouse once a week you you you you
basically fold it closed put it back in
his cage so he eats in a different
environment so that he does not get the
idea that I eat in this terrarium
because then you might stick your hand
in there he thinks it's a snake thinks
it's a mouse and eats it so in pinky I
think you pee eventually as the snake
gets bigger you got to like have a
feeding like if you got a huge snake
like a 20 foot snake you gotta have like
a feeding bin you know and then in that
point you're like giving it a rat to eat
the guy I saw somebody I was in line a
woman comes in she's like I want one of
the large rats the guy reaches in the
fridge pulls it out holding it just a
dead rat and that's like a couple of
times a year for that for that big snake
though I think no maybe every 10 to 14
days I don't know but but man moose is
once a week my Christmas is over and you
ruined it
it's just the reality man it's the
circle of life
where's Elton John when you need him
so after everybody got their presents
open everybody's playing the new guitars
and Lando is loading up his gumball
machine he asked for a gumball machine
you're next on this is another machine
this is a gumball machine ok good
Smallin we got that Oh No mice in there
but you could probably put the little
pinky mice in the little balls that
would be kind of cool we did we could
put that in Shepards room and that's
where he gets the mice where the corn
snake crawls up and stuff but the corn
snake in the in the gum Amish that'd be
cool your terrarium yeah we did not get
land Oh a claw machine like he asked for
because the reasons that I told him you
know be overkill and then you know in
the in the effort to further traditions
but like Lily's gonna make a meal she
made this beef stroganoff meal for our
dinner and we're all sitting down at the
table like gathered around eating our
meal this is this is the evening
Christmas evening by this point and
we're sitting down and we're eating this
meal that my daughter prepared it's
fabulous
everybody's happy he's got their stuff
and I just find myself weeping at the
table like I was I literally found
myself weeping tears of joy you know the
at my table the here's the thing though
is that you know 20 years from now
you're gonna start the estrogen is
really gonna be getting produced yeah at
that point you will many men find
themselves weeping for no reason nothing
but weep you're getting started at 40
yeah you just need to gotta pace
yourself a little bit it kind of caught
the fam off guard a little bit
and I think Christie knew what was
happening and maybe she maybe she teared
up a little bit maybe she gave me a pat
on the shoulder and but the realization
I was having was just tremendous
gratitude for this this family
I mean you've got these people who are
that they're their own people but like
we you know they we made them and in a
certain sense and yeah well I I think
specifically it was the it was the first
time in a long time that we had our own
Christmas thing and it was that we had
our own thing for the first time that
was distinct from the rest of our family
I mean in we missed them
we missed our family not being there but
and I was a little sad about that and we
did talk to them and do video chats
throughout the day and stuff like that
but I realized that I actually felt very
much the the very fatherly for the first
time and I started thinking about
feeling father traditions but because
when the rest of your family is there
when your parents or maybe older
siblings or other extended family is
there it relationships go up and they go
down in time but when it was just us
I was the you know I was the I was the
only father around so it was a very
different feeling that kind of snuck up
on me that's like we have a thing and I
think that it was something that my
feeling like my that that encouraged us
to do our own thing I think they knew
better than I did that it's like yes you
need you need to have this sensation and
I realized that I just had not had it
and that in and I when I realized that I
was having it I started to cry and it
was very I was very happy does this mean
that you had you're gonna like this is
Christmas now like you're not gonna be
home I don't yeah I don't know I mean we
as long as a lot keeps playing
basketball we have to be here so I'm I
don't have a choice for four years but
it was I mean at this point what we
haven't taught about that specifically
so I don't know exactly
it was pretty moving it was very moving
so yeah that is that is a big tick in
the yes column of let's do this again
let's continue to build on this
well I will say I I cared up at the
Christmas meal but it was because I
nearly burned the house down and it was
just the smoke coming from the oven what
yeah um and but it was beef I'm sure
this was my wife's fault so go for it it
wasn't beef stroganoff it was beef
wellington oh that's not easy well so
Jesse's parents had been in town they
left we had a couple of days did we kind
of did some just us McLaughlin's thing
and then Jesse sister and her her family
so husband and two boys about you know
high school-age boys so a little older
than lock we're gonna come state but
they flew in on Christmas Day and so
we're like okay well we're gonna prepare
Christmas dinner and so we can all have
it together when they get there uh-huh
and Jesse and I you know we we fancy
ourselves is you know culinarily skilled
although we're not but we're of
interests and we're like well she's like
well I'm gonna do these Cornish hens
because we do Cornish hens every year as
I got our Christmas dinner before we go
back home but now we're gonna make it a
Christmas dinner but I was like wait
what have we tried beef wellington you
know ever since I watched that first
season of Hell's Kitchen and heard
Gordon Ramsay talk about it I had this
idea of how awesome it would be to make
beef wellington so we made all of them
at the same time and ambitious we ended
up like we couldn't put the all of it in
the oven at the same time and because we
ended up putting the hands directly on
the grate in the oven and I put these
drip pans underneath it and then
everything was dripping off of the
Cornish hens and it was smoking up the
house and the fire alarm kept going off
and it was freezing as you know for LA
it was freezing on Christmas Day for
what you know was it is in the 40s can
you believe it which is super cold to us
at this point
mm-hmm you know we've adjusted so I got
all the windows and doors open I did did
tear up a little bit but again it was
because of the smoke and the ice there
were no flames though nose no flames and
actually the yelling the meal
Jesse and I um yeah a little bit
Christmas Day yelling I mean there's
it's like that's part of it like
Christmas if you're not yelling yeah
it's part of and the meal was really
good it ended up being great and nothing
was burned it was just the drippings had
created the smoke situation okay um I
don't know if I'm gonna make that
smoking up the house a tradition but it
is the kind of thing that becomes a
tradition you know like you tell the
story of the time the whole house got
smoked up and then like 400 years later
like there's like a dude with incense
he's like we like this incense in honor
of the time Rhett and Jesse McLaughlin
nearly burn their house down like that's
how tradition starts always well that
sounds more like a religion and I'm
starting a religion as 2019 the year I
started religion and then so then I
embarked on my trip when I don't want to
get it was just really quick okay
because I had everybody I had every I
had family there for those two different
periods of time and I learned something
about my dog I'll show a picture at the
appropriate time here on the feed but my
dog is unfaithful Barbara is unfaithful
oh well I needed that you know that
Barbara likes to it seeks attention from
whoever is there but when Jesse's
parents were there she slept in the bed
with Jesse's parents of course Jesse's
whole family they're all dog people they
don't care they love her they think
she's incredible yeah so they're not
it's not like a barber tried to sleep
with my parents who would be a little
different but Sir Barbara is like
sleeping with the enemy not anybody
oh you said it you said and sleeping
with Jesse's parents and then sleeping
with
Jesse's sister and her husband and even
going to the point of getting in their
suitcase I have a picture I'll show it
now this is Barbara in for those of you
who are watching the plight cast like
trying to I don't know if she's trying
to send the message I want to go home
I hate it here because she seems to love
us as well because what she'll do is
she'll spend all night down there and
then in the morning she'll come and get
and start scratching at our door and
then once it's come in and just make out
with me you know I'm saying I'm not
making out with you right now you've
been you've been making out with with
other people downstairs
that's not time for that but you did let
her in yeah I do I can't help it she
also wore sweater pretty much the entire
holiday season Oh festive yeah it was
just I don't know what did she think
about the snake does not care about
moose at all
well doesn't bark at him doesn't look at
him doesn't sniff him Shepherd brought
him down Christmas Day
holding him Barbara doesn't care we were
wondering if she was gonna freak out
like Barbara see the snake uh yes she
seemed to but she didn't seem to care
about it maybe she would maybe she was
friends with the snake in a previous
life I don't know now if she if she gets
in the aquarium with the snake I know
that's what not what it's called but
whatever then terrarium you're really
being cheated on like you should really
take that personally she's curled up
with the snake he might try so after
Christmas we went we went to Sedona
Arizona because again like I said last
year biscuit we decided not to do the RV
thing we want to get there quick we were
the place that I found it had a great
view out the window of the Red Rocks
that our signature for Sedona
unfortunately we couldn't take Jade
because they wouldn't allow her in this
place and that was my one regret that
Jade was not with us but um this place I
mean a lot of friends had told us about
it and they talked it up and that's why
I wanted to go and I knew there was a
lot of good day hiking and I'm so trying
to foster the love for the nature with
my family and taking nature walks I
don't call them hikes cuz it's like
we've talked about before my kids have
decided they don't they don't think they
like to hike so you just call it
something else good day and it works or
just don't tell them you're doing it
just tell me oh we're walking to the car
but we're going to take an alternate
and then lo and behold we're out here in
nature for three hours and they're
loving it that so that was my vision you
can do a scavenger hunt out there as
well just so you know I mean they did
it'd be pretty fun outdoors this is a
you could do a spiritual scavenger hunt
because this place is like I mean call
it new agey okay in the 70s there was
some psychic woman who went there and
said oh this is a this is a this is a
hotbed of spiritual earth energy
activity and there are because you go in
and there's it's a two-lane road that
kind of goes through into kind of a
valley that then you're driving past
these red rock formations on either side
of the road and it's absolutely
breathtakingly beautiful it's like this
want to read Red Rocks the theater no no
we're John Tesh played no but it is it's
the same it is the same type of rocks I
do leave you know that iron content you
got like a rust situation going on and
the erosion exposes these amazing
looking formations there's one there's
one Natural Bridge called Devil's Bridge
that you can hike to I ended up not
going for weather reasons so I'll have
to go back but I mean it's absolutely
beautiful so in the 70s it was
determined to be this like place where
there was a lot of spiritual energy
going in and coming out of the earth in
places called vortex vortexes which we
learned about vortexes back when we went
to Tonopah Nevada as part of commercial
Kings where we made a tourism ad for
them for that episode and I'm still
reasonably proud of that episode and I
saw the sign for Tonopah when we were
driving when we're gonna pause as a
vortex that's what they say right yeah
we ended up you know so there's a lot of
it's very hippy spiritual so you got the
beautiful scenery
lots of people hiking lots of shops with
lots of crystals where each Kris
does something special other than just
sit there and be Iraq right right and
there's four vortexes
there's four yeah Nona's got four it's
got four and how many how many
cheesecake fighters have zero Wow so way
that when you're here and we signed up
for a Jeep tour for one day but as I was
looking for that there was also a vortex
tour that I thought about taking where
the description was written by the one
tour guide who said if you have a party
of four or less you meet me at this gas
station and you can get in my car and I
will drive you to the vortexes you can
experience a male vortex a female vortex
and general spiritual goodness if you
have a party of five or more I'll get in
the car with you and we'll do the same
so at that point I just I didn't I
didn't pursue that one any further big
around is a vortex well I'm thinking
about how big the party is I'm gonna
take right do we all get in one at a
time or do we all there's a whole group
get it and can you feel it it's not a
whole no it's like a tornado it's like a
spiritual tornado it's pretty big one
like for one there's a Brock called Bell
Rock which is pretty freaking big but
you can if you were physically capable
you could hike up to the top of the bell
in an hour okay so that gives you an
idea how big it is it's shaped looking
like a bell we hiked this it is a vortex
the entire formation is a vortex is a
vortex okay that's all I can say about
it you didn't having feel it did you
feel it I felt joy being there I felt
exhilaration and a little fear climbing
up because lando kept wanting to climb
up and I kept saying climbing up is easy
buddy
it's the climbing down that's difficult
but in a vortex you have to worry about
gravity that's what he said oh and I was
like no I'm
buying it so every every so often I
would make him crawl ahead and then
prove to me that he could crawl back
down and the rest of the family had long
since bailed on this entire they didn't
go up into the vortex
we went halfway up the bell and then we
went we went another third of the way up
beautiful place just can't I I have
nothing more to say about a vortex I
don't know I just didn't experience
anything may I should have signed up for
the tour
you weren't open I should have got you
were closed we should have got the woman
in our car you have to open your heart
in the same way that the vortex is open
and you need to understand it I we did
have a couple of magical experiences the
first one we get there that night we're
eating pizza and the employees at the
place say oh look it's it's um it's
there's a snow flurry it's the first of
the season was it going in a knoteks
pattern it was not that would have been
that would have been important for me
they went outside and say wow they don't
they actually don't get a lot of snow
there and because I was reading online
it's like if you're hiking you might be
lucky and there might be a dusting of
snow on the Red Rocks which can be
beautiful
turns out Lando had never seen it didn't
realize this he had never seen falling
natural falling snow you know cuz we've
been out here since he was before he was
2 years old and because haven't he
hasn't seen snowfall except for a man
made at a ski resort last last year this
time right that was special but then the
next day I take him out hiking or on a
nature walk
wink wink and it starts snowing and we
went on a hike dude in the snow and it
was absolutely it was awesome I mean
this is where I saw some of the
instagrams from your family right yeah
it's like nothing I mean it's like you
could go your whole life and not
hiking's in in snow falling on the Red
Rocks especially in Sedona from what
I've heard it was pretty special
like we had a blast cry then I had a
little tear tear actually there's no
beef stroganoff involved no no no you
need to isolate and what the trigger is
trying to correlate what it is if it's
not beef stroganoff it may be just being
with your family in heaven and you know
having good times
well how sad is that
it's got to be something else today the
next day we took a jeep tour which
turned out to be actually kind of lame
but you can rent jeeps there and do like
aggressive off-roading which a lot of
place you can't do that so that's
another cool thing about that if you
want to go to Sedona not a sponsor
Sedona not a entire town not as upon the
next the last day we're there it starts
snowing we go out for brunch and this is
an unexpected snow but and it's dumping
snow by the time we come out an hour and
a half later we had driven four minutes
to eat brunch we come out we get back in
the car
it's like seven inches of snow it's
crazy it was amazing it took us over two
hours to drive the four minute drive
back to our condo because the place just
wasn't ready for it it shut down and we
drove for an hour we didn't move hardly
anything I was like alright you guys get
out just walk home and they had they had
a blast just kind of walking home in the
in the snow blast and I had some alone
time with my vortex that's not it weird
I was just in the car listening but I
listened to like four texts spa music it
was it was really got to get everything
in life it was really and then we get
back home have some coffee I finally get
there and the sun's going down I'm like
we can hike back up this trail from our
condo and Lando and I went out there and
that's the picture that I showed in LA
at that I got him to take of me and I
get up there to the top and dude I swear
this is when I cried again I was like
Lando this is the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen it would there was snow
on this trail and your view of the Red
Rocks
and like it was as quiet as Christmas
Eve before Santa and I called Kristi I
was like you bail on this but you have
to get dressed and you have to hike up
here and see this and she came up there
and she was like tearing up it was so
beautiful up there and so quiet and she
was
like this is like Narnia I thought about
you and your obsession with Narnia dude
I went to in a limp I went to winter
Narnia no lamppost wasn't Narnia take
lots of photos in my like did you find
any goat tracks no okay it wasn't
actually Narnia I get it but just once
it was just shoot just a set of two
because that was his because he was half
goat I mean the entire the entire thing
I was just you know I was just struck
with for for my family I try to adopt
this mentality but then I'm trying to
apply it to life in a new year's
resolution type way is just trying to
say maybe we've talked about this but to
set up you can't you can't create
moments like that or all the moments
that we had the tear up moments but you
can create you can you can set the table
for something memorable to happen for
the place to get filled up with smoke so
to speak you know and it's just there's
an art to saying okay I can't force this
but I can set the table for something
amazing
we can go here we can go to this place
and do a walk and maybe the snow will
dump
maybe something magical will happen it
was totally different trip it snowed and
I you know I can't say it's not related
to the vortex but the vortex isn't at
your house why not maybe you have a
vortex in your head maybe I do any
vortexes make you cry I don't slightly
different slightly different no snow in
Mexico well how Alicia's I enjoyed being
with the family that we had in town
uh-huh
but I have a certain capacity for just
people in my house and regardless of how
well we're getting along and the fun
that we're having we get it we had a
great time as families we watched a lot
of movies I saw a bird box suddenly all
the memes made sense it's all Aquaman I
watched my wife watch Jason Momoa and
that was interesting but then I got to
take in Amber Heard in sort of a similar
way which I had license to do that
in her in her aqua suit or whatever it
was I heard and and then so we said we
saw movies and but by the end of it I
was kind of like I am I kind of neat and
I knew this and this is why I planned
this trip to Cabo was just Jesse I was
like I'm gonna need some time to myself
and just me and my wife after having
everybody in town so we went down to
Cabo it's for like four days and had a
very relaxing time actually ended up
working if I don't call it work because
I don't like writing songs and working
on some other things that we can't tell
him about but stuff that was stuff that
you could do next to a pool and sort of
a relaxing fashion and I got the and did
the photo shoot which which you know I'm
very proud of well you got a fill you
got a fill the listeners in because they
don't know what the photo shoot is did
you say I don't think you said that well
huh no yeah so when we got to this place
they were orienting or in orienting us
to what was you know the options in the
place and they were like oh there's a
complimentary photo shoot you know I
knew that my complimentary photo shoot
they met somebody's gonna take photos of
you and then charge you a lot of money
for the photos that they took it's not
really complimentary so the shoot is
free but the photos are expansive but
Jesse had gotten me this watermelon
bathing suit and matching watermelon
shirt almost as a joke not ever thinking
I would wear them together I've worn
them both independently I think I'm more
the watermelon shirt on the show at one
point but I put the whole package
together if you if there's any place to
do it as Cabo and I was like this is
what I'm wearing for the photo shoot
what are you wearing
so Jesse and I took some photos together
but then I was like obviously I gotta
get something by myself I mean this is
kind of a special outfit okay know what
tell me why that was obvious just
because you say you saw the photo I
think I created a vortex in Cabo I mean
I don't know how the vortex has happened
but if there was not abort
around me while I had that watermelon
suit on on the beach that I don't
believe in for Texas and here the
interesting thing was is you know me of
the two of us I'm the one that is a
little more worried about what people
think
mm-hm and and also I'm always I'm very
overly irrationally sensitive to how big
I am I'm just a very large person so I
kind of feel like if I do anything if I
get out there and dance it whatever I do
you're gonna see me do it because I
can't miss me right right and so I have
you're not even factoring in being
covered in watermelon right and so I'm
like I got to put this watermelon thing
on I'm gonna walk all around this resort
getting cold feet on us no I knew I was
gonna do it but I couldn't just relax
into it I wanted to just relax into my
identif my identity as the guy who wears
the watermelon outfit I wasn't wanted to
be that guy but in as I'm getting that
picture taken all the people who are
eating breakfast at the restaurant that
overlooks the beach or just like looking
at me like look at this douche you know
I'm saying this guy I obviously thinks
this is cool and I want to be able to be
like I know that this is funny I don't
know why and I told you I see I was like
that's my new year's resolution it's
just just quit caring quit caring about
what people think create your own vortex
be your own vortex that's what my
t-shirt says but Photoshop the leg wound
after I will add that no but you know
what that's an airbrush it's all part of
the story though it's all part of the
story and you know that's that's the in
by the time this is out that picture
will be on my Instagram as well I mean
shout-out to red MC on Instagram I
haven't done that in a while but you
know what there's a vortex happening
over there on Instagram right now and
you could be a part of it
maybe if you double-click that picture
you'll create your own vortex right
there with your thumb I don't know how
the internet works but if you want to
get into my vortex create your own
vortex we'll have them just a web of
vortexes maybe the whole world will
become a vortex and it start
going over to red MC and liking that
photo sorry
so I I that was kind of I mean it's kind
of selfish I realized that I mean you
know especially in contrasted with how
you wept you wept in the presence of
your family for me I think my holidays
really just comes down to that single
photo of me in the watermelons nope I
had an incredible time with my wife it
was we needed the time even though it
was just a few days I got offered coke
on the streets of Cabo you know by at
least seven people like Diet Coke it was
the diet coke and that cherry coke and
just coke classic Coke Zero they had
every kind of coke that you could
imagine how was it I didn't I didn't
trust it you know I just didn't trust it
and I didn't say yes to that okay for
the record you said no said no I am NOT
interested in that but one of the more
notable things I'll never forget and
it's one of those things that there's
these things that happen to you and then
they become part of your your personal
canon whenever you interact with it
object and let me explain we have some
of these things between the two of us
I'm at the pool and I order a quesadilla
you know it's like pull side restaurant
they'll bring you whatever you want yeah
great service would love it and they
bring me a quesadilla and the guy comes
and sets it down and it's you know it's
that sort of the half moon it's it's the
folded over tortilla as a quesadilla is
pretty recognizable food product okay in
an old old man walks by comes up he's
like what do you call that
really yes he said what do you call that
and I was like a quesadilla is like and
instead of saying like oh I didn't I
didn't know it's quesadilla like yes
like he was like huh
and then he goes over and starts talking
to his wife and like they discover honey
I introduced someone to a case I do
you'll never believe this thing and so
then you and you'll never yeah you'll
never believe how they spell it so so
again now this is what I'm getting at
this whole personal Canon thing which is
one of the things I love about life so
then when we when when Jesse and I are
at the airport getting ready to mm-hmm
leave Cabo and because we have a certain
credit card we get into this lounge area
oh I know what they had and they had a
quesadilla and I bring it back and put
it I got on my plate I yeah I'm like we
had a little share and so now for the
rest of my life any time I'm with my
wife and we order a quesadilla one of us
is gonna say as couple cannon yeah a
couple cannon man you got it what can't
in quesadilla yeah that's it that's rate
your own vortex that's the thing about
you know relationships hey wait you know
we're 18 19 years in the marriage at a
couple of years when dating it's like
you got it you got to keep adding to the
couple cannon yeah you got to you know
and so and quesadillas are so prevalent
that's good that's a good reminder that
we're not we're hands for all going
except where that guy's from now not a
sponsor one of the last things I'd like
to do is this was the president and my
wife got for me in which is she thought
I would like a 360 camera she was right
Oh Jacob Kiko I warned Kiko about this
I'm gonna take I'm taking a big for his
pants his knees out oh my knees are out
I hope this is gonna work I'm gonna take
a 360 degree photo of our studio right
now and then I'm going to I don't where
can you post 360 degree photos just take
it I'm gonna tweet out wherever you have
to rotate it oh you take it one two
three that was it huh it's like it's
like men in black oh really chop him up
on it well you can better you better
believe it if it can be on Instagram it
will be shout out the red MC
if not I'm gonna tweet it out all right
well man so we've caught up here we are
holidays caught up we got 20 19 is just
bustling now before us and let's let's
walk that red carpet shall we together
every week we're gonna bring you another
year biscuit let's go through 2019
together bring your friends along go to
iTunes or wherever you're listening
could be Spotify I don't know wherever
else leave a review
now all that stuff helps but bring
bringing people into this world of
friendship and honesty
laughs tears the friendship vortex all
of it might be that might be the
subtitle for 2019 this air biscuits do
it thank you for hanging out with us I
mean shoot
Conan's got a podcast now yeah yeah I
mean I mean as the competition's getting
stiff where I don't know what's gonna
you probably shouldn't have even
mentioned his yeah take it back we take
it back he doesn't have a podcast don't
wait don't go looking for it we'll talk
with you next week only us or at least
us first I don't know one of the other
things I did I didn't get to I'll just
tell you be quick but we're eating
dinner in Sedona and in the place and
like I was playing music I was playing
like the Lord Huron and I was like when
I'm just thinking a lot about the kids
when when they get older and I was
thinking like you know 20 20 years from
now I'm 60 like I would love to know
that I could like rent a place and have
the family come back and I was like I
was saying this I was like Lily you're
gonna 20 years from now you're gonna be
you're gonna be 35 years old you might
have you know might have a partner and
have kids and Lincoln who knows what
you'll be doing land oh I don't know you
know be 28 you guys could all have lives
you'll have lives of your own you know
what if I bring you back and we're all
hanging out like after Christmas and
some vortex
and would you what if you had this idea
that like you were gonna go over to
whatever the way music was played and
you go over and you would play something
like would you even know as it as like a
sweet moment would you even know the
music that your dad always played in the
house when you were growing up like
would you even know what that is like
when I was a kid I know my mom played Al
Green and Lionel Richie is so important
to me now and Michael Jackson like I
know that she that's the stuff that was
played would you know that like do you
know who this is this plane right now
and they were like Fleet Foxes and I was
like that's wrong but that's good and
that would have worked it's Lord Huron
so 20 years from now when we're all
together I don't want you to say a word
I want you to go over look I was talking
to Lily she's the most reliable one I
felt like it would this kind of promise
I want you to in whatever way music is
played when we're all together 20 years
from now you got lives of your own but
we're all back together I want you to
play some learn Lord Huron and then I'm
gonna start hearing it and I'm gonna
remember this moment and I want you to
promise that you're gonna remember this
and it's gonna be called the Lord Huron
promise well shorten it to just the
Huron promise because the Lord promise
sounds like something's probably already
taken and she was like okay dad you're
being weird oh really but I made a
promise
20 years from now 20 38 I'm gonna be
with my family and all of a sudden this
song's gonna play and my daughter will
have remembered the promise
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]